This suspected Chinese spy balloon
entered U.S.
airspace eight days ago,
two Saturdays ago in Alaska.
Once it became clear
that this was not an accident,
why did the U.S.
not shoot it down then?
Well, again,
the president gave instructions
to have it
handled, to have it
shot down in a way that was safe.
As you may have seen, there's reporting
now that the debris field
that was created by this balloon
when it was shot down
was about seven miles long.
And so
any time
the military is considering an operation
like that,
they have to consider the safety
of the American people.
The president called for this
to be dealt with
in a way that
balanced all of the different risks.
That's exactly what happened.
Military did a terrific job.
From our perspective in the DOT.
Of course, our main concern
is the safety of the national airspace.
This thing was above
where flight operations happened.
And so any debris would have passed
through that national airspace.
But the FAA works very closely
with the Pentagon in this case,
had to do ground stops
on those airports
on the Eastern Seaboard,
close off
some of the airspace
to make sure that everything was safe.
And secure during the operation.
And as you know, the operation took place
without any damage
or injury
to any American lives or property.
Obviously, that's great
that there were no Americans
hurt by this.
But is it acceptable
that there were eight days
that the spy satellites above spy
balloon was over
the United States,
then Canada, then again
over the United States
from Idaho, Montana,
all the way through the Carolinas
for day after day?
What is the U.S.
has communicated?
It's not acceptable at all.
That China sent this object
into our airspace.
But in terms of how to handle it.
That's something that was done
based on assessment of the risks,
making sure that there was no
risk that
outweighed the
risks in terms of any damage
that would come.
It was handled appropriately.
So you say there was a seven mile
debris field over the Atlantic Ocean
where it was shot down.
Can you tell us what,
if anything, has been able
to be recovered?
Obviously, there's a lot of interest in
in getting the material,
getting the debris and,
you know,
being able
to conduct intelligence
operations of our own
of the United States
zone against
the Chinese for this balloon.
I really can't add
anything on the tactics and the timing
and the manner of it.
Ultimately, of course,
comes to the Pentagon.
I'm just glad that there was no damage
or threat to U.S.
aviation operations
and that this operation took place
was done
in a very effective, excellent way,
as you would expect
from the American military,
without any consequences
for Americans on the ground.
So obviously,
there are a lot of concerns
being expressed by senators
and governors.
The balloon might have flown
and gathered
intelligence over
sensitive parts
of the United States infrastructure.
There's Malmstrom Air Force Base
and nuclear ballistic
missile fields in Montana.
If you look at the map there,
Whiteman Air Force
Base in Missouri, Scott
Air Force Base in Illinois,
Fort Bragg and Camp
Lejeune in North Carolina,
is the assumption
that the balloon was able
to gather sensitive information
and transmit
it back to the Chinese government.
Although the U.S.
has stated
that steps were taken to prevent
any problems
in terms of intelligence collection.
Remember,
we are talking about a country
that has a space program.
So I don't know
all of the ins
and outs
of what this balloon was doing or
what its capabilities were.
I do know that when the president
gave the order to have this handled,
the military gauged
the different risks and the different
benefits of different approaches,
made the decisions that they did
Brought this thing down without incident.
Right.
But the presumption
has got to be
that the Chinese were able
to gather intelligence
hovering over the United States for day
after day,
especially over
some of these sensitive sites.
I'm sure there's a similar presumption
about what spy satellites do.
That is well outside of my lane.
I'm just glad that nobody was hurt
as this thing came down.
When did the Biden administration
first learn about this balloon, the spy
balloon entering U.S.
airspace?
We're told it first did so.
It first entered U.S.
airspace over Alaska
two Saturdays at ago.
Is that when the Biden administration
learned about it?
I really can't speak to that.
What I can speak to
is the great cooperation
we have between the FAA
and the Pentagon
to make sure
that when you have
a special military operation
like what it took to bring down
this balloon,
that it happens without any threat
to American lives or property.
Lastly, on this topic,
will there be consequences
beyond shooting it down?
Will the Chinese government
be sanctions or sanctioned
or penalized in any way?
Well, the U.S.
has made clear
this is an unacceptable intrusion
into American sovereignty.
And I think you can expect that
that any further developments
will be appropriate
in response to what happened.
So President
Biden is going to be delivering
this State
of the Union address on Tuesday.
He's going to have a new person
sitting behind him.
The new Republican House
Speaker, Kevin McCarthy.
Anything President
Biden wants to get done
over the next two years
other than executive actions
will have to go through Kevin McCarthy.
Should we expect the president to lay out
a long list of things
that are never going to happen under
House Republican leadership?
Or is it going to be about ways
and places
where Republicans
and Democrats can work together, areas
where there are common interests?
Well, I'm really looking forward
to the State of the Union
because first of all,
there are so many accomplishments
to talk about.
And many of those accomplishments
happened on a bipartisan basis.
You remember
there was a lot of almost snickering
when the president took office
saying that it would be possible
to deliver
historic infrastructure
legislation, historic
economic legislation,
and do it on a bipartisan basis.
But that's what happened.
And so I think the hand continues
to be outstretched
to anyone,
including anyone across the aisle,
who's prepared
to work with us to get things done.
But let's talk about
what we have to show for that,
even just in the two years
that the administration has been here.
We just saw the latest round
of job numbers that came out.
Record low
unemployment, lowest
we've had in more than 50 years.
And usually
when unemployment is that low,
inflation is going up.
Right now, inflation is going down
along with unemployment.
We're talking about
the most jobs
created under any president
in this period, a matter of fact.
President creating more jobs in two years
than you have seen typically in four.
And coupled
with things
that Republicans often say that is
is very important
to them, like deficit reduction
and historic
reduction of the deficit
to the tune of 1.7 trillion.
Under this president,
you look at
what's been done in two years
and I think the president's
going to be going into this State
of the Union speech
with a context of extraordinary
historic accomplishment.
And with that,
I think is a wind at our back,
even with a house
that is now
of course, in the hands
of the opposite party to say, okay,
what else can we get done
for the benefit of the American people,
first and foremost,
to keep this extraordinary
economic growth going
and then to deal with other priorities
that matter to people,
whether they are in red, blue
or purple areas.
So just a few days ago,
the chief of staff Ron Klain,
left the White House.
And in his farewell remarks,
he referred to President Biden
running for reelection in 20, 24.
He'll be 81 on election day in 2024.
Republicans such as Ron DeSantis
and Nikki Haley
are already seeming
to make a generational argument.
Whether that's aimed at Biden or Trump
that doesn't really matter
they're both in advanced years.
You made a similar generational argument
when you were running against Joe
Biden for president yourself.
Are you worried that it could work
in 2024
generational arguments can be powerful
as you said I've used them myself.
The most powerful argument of all
is results
and you can't argue,
at least
I would say
you can't argue with a straight face
that it isn't a good thing
that we have had
12 million jobs
created under this president
and by the way
a lot of the jobs are in manufacturing.
As someone who grew up in
the industrial Midwest.
It's been so moving to see
hundreds of thousands of good paying
manufac lecturing jobs being created
including in rural areas,
small towns in places
like tennessee
and louisiana and georgia and indiana.
The kind of growth that benefits
the entire american people.
And I think when you look at that,
when you look at
what america was up against
when president biden took office
and what has been delivered again
just in these
first two years of this administration,
let alone
what's possible
as we actually start
entering more and more, for example,
of the construction phase
on the infrastructure law.
And I think those results
are going to continue
to accumulate
and people will toss whatever argument
they can into the mix that they think
is going to benefit them the most.
But at the end of the day,
you can't argue
with the extraordinary accomplishments
more than almost
any other modern president,
the present Biden has achieved, again,
under the toughest of circumstances.
Speaking of the industrial Midwest.
You recently moved
from a Republican
leaning in industrial Midwest state
Indiana
to a Democratic leaning
industrial Midwest state
Michigan Senator
Debbie Stabenow
announced that she is not going to be
running for reelection.
You and your husband and two kids have.
Residents in Michigan
are you going to be seeking
that Senate seat?
No, but I really hope you're not.
I'm planning to vote in that election
as a resident of Michigan.
But look at the job that I have is,
first of all,
I think
the best job in the federal government
can be really tough and demanding
with all of the problems
that the transportation system
has confronted.
But also incredibly rewarding.
And I'm proud
to be part of an administration
that is doing more on transportation
than has happened in my lifetime
and then some
not since the Eisenhower administration
have we had this much going on
in terms of fixing roads
and bridges in this country,
not since Amtrak was created.
Have we done more to improve rail service
in this country.
This job is taking 110% of my time.
And obviously I serve
at the pleasure of the president.
But as long as
he is willing to have me continue
doing this work,
I'm proud to be part of this team.